Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ucak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesigespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich, Dr.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Horst Los.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam mustibieren?
Heinrich Otto Richard Samuel Theodor Horst. Mein Nachname Ludwig Otto double Samuel, double S.
Okay. Herr Los, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
65. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
12. März 1960.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 60.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zu seit?
Ich bin 560 Kilo.
Okay. Danke für die Informations- und Herr Los. Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zu seit?
Ja, Dr. Ich habe starke Kliniken und Rückenschmerzen.
Welche Seite meinen Sie?
Das ist die rechte Seite.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen, Herr Los?
Es ist ungefähr anderthalb Stunden, Dr.
Okay. Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Also sind Sie eher drückend oder kolikartig rennend?
Ja. Diese Schmerzen sind krampfartig, Dr.
Okay. Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Ja, Dr. Es ist verfallen für mich. Manchmal dauerhaft, manchmal gehen wir wieder weg.
Okay. Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja. Die Schmerzen strahlen bis in die rechte Leiste aus.
Okay. Herr Los, haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, Dr.
Und haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe 600 Milligramm Überprofen eingenommen, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Okay. Sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich, Dr.
Alles klar. Herr Los, haben Sie eine Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe nur eine Allergie, Dr.
Okay. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber ich habe außerdem auch jetzt Handdrang und Schmerzen bei Wasserlassen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Was meinen Sie?
Ich meine eine chronische Erkrankung, von der ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, Dr. Ich bin nicht Arzt, Dr.
Okay, also ich werde die Schwester Bescheid sagen und sie gibt Ihnen eine Schmerzmitte. Okay?
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt? Besser oder?
Ja, jetzt fühle ich mich besser, Dr. Danke schön.
Okay, darf ich fragen, wie stark waren Ihre Schmerzen, bevor Sie dieses Medikament auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ich denke 10. Ich hatte sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen. Aber jetzt fühle ich mich besser, Dr. Danke schön.
Ja, sehr gerne. Bitte sagen Sie mir sofort Bescheid, wenn Sie ein Medikament benötigen, okay?
Okay, okay.
Herr Los, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen haben, also schmerzhaftes Wasserlassen zum Beispiel.
Sonst haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Probleme beim Wasserlassen? Ich meine Blut im Urin?
Ja, Dr. Ich gestern und heute habe ich Blut in meinem Urin bemerkt, ja, Dr.
Okay. Wie oft müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen, Herr Los?
Sehr oft. Ich muss 6 oder 8 oder 10, ich bin nicht sicher jetzt, müssen auf die Toilette gehen, ja.
Aber kleine Menge, meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, kleine.
Okay, alles klar. Herr Los, leiden Sie unter, also haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Ja, ich habe nicht gemessen, Dr. Aber Sie haben Recht, ich fühle mich ein bisschen fiebrig, ja. Ich fühle mich heiß, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, nein.
Okay, Herr Los, haben Sie gemessen, also gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert, eine bestimmte Körperposition oder Wärmfläche vielleicht?
Ich habe keine Situation oder andere Bemerkte ausgelöst, nein.
Okay, alles klar. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, Dr. Sattli, ich bin übel, ja.
Mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ja, ich musste zweimal Grundliche Flüssigkeit erbrechen, ja.
Wie sieht das Erbrechen aus? Ich meine, haben Sie Blut im ...?
Grundliche, Grundliche.
Grundliche, okay.
Ja, ich habe nicht Blut bemerkt.
Okay, das freut mich. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist nicht gut, doch.
Wegen der Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, zwei Schmerzen, ja. Stärke Schmerzen.
Ich verstehe.
Aber es ist sehr interessant. In den letzten Wochen habe ich etwas Gewicht zugenommen, Doktor. Obwohl ich kaum Appetit habe, ja.
Ja, wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie zugenommen?
Ich denke zwei oder drei Kilogramm, ja.
Drei Kilogramm in einer Woche, ja?
Ja.
Okay, alles klar. Schlafen Sie gut? Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, schlafen ist nicht gut, Doktor. Ich habe deswegen diese Schmerzen. Ich schlafe nicht gut, ja.
Einzuschlagprobleme oder Durchschlagprobleme oder beides vielleicht?
Beides, beides, ja.
Okay. Herr Los, ist alles in Ordnung mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, Doktor. Ich hatte langen chronischen Durchfall. Aber zurzeit habe ich das nicht.
Okay, alles klar. Und seit wann leiden Sie an chronischen Durchfall?
Es ist sehr lange, ungefähr zehn Jahre.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, Doktor. Mein Herz hat auch mir gesagt, dass ich wahrscheinlich ein Reisdarmzentrum habe.
Ja, aber ich nehme bei Bedarf, wenn ich wieder Durchfall habe, nehme ich Parenterol.
Okay, alles klar. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten oder Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht, besonders ins Ausland?
Eine Reise gemacht? Ja, nein. Ich bin Renter. Ich bin kein Geld, Doktor.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Okay. Herr Los, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich habe seit 15 Jahren Bluthochdruck, ja.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig dagegen ein Medikament?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig Rami-Pril, 10 mg, morgens.
Sonst noch?
Ja, Doktor. Seit 14 Jahren eine Sehnscheideentzündung. Sehnscheideentzündung.
In welchen Körperregionen meinen Sie?
Rechts.
Elbe oder Handgelenk?
Handgelenk, ja. Das hat mir mein Arzt damals gesagt, Doktor.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme bei Bedarf die Klofenak-Salbe.
Okay. Sonst noch? Etwas?
Ja, ich habe gesagt Reise-Darm-Syndrom.
Und ja, vor zwei Jahren wurde mir ein Ganglion an der rechten Hand festgestellt.
So eine Geschuhe am Handgelenk. Aber das wurde nicht operiert.
Okay, dieser Ganglion wurde konservativ behandelt. Ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden. Nein, ich war nicht operiert.
Okay, das freut mich. Herr Luss, nehmen Sie außer genannten Medikamenten noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein, Doktor.
Regenmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Ich habe gesagt, aber ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay, verstehe. Ist Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich bin gegen Grazepolen-Allergie, Doktor.
Wie auslöst sich diese Allergie?
Da bekomme ich Schnupfen und es juckt überall.
Juckreiz?
Ja, Juckreiz.
Sonst noch etwas?
Ja, ich habe auch eine Laktosintoleranz, Doktor.
Wenn ich etwas mit mir esse, bekomme ich Blähungen, Bauchschmerzen und manchmal Durchfall.
Okay. Herr Luss, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche ja, Doktor.
Seit wann und wie viel?
Seit 30 Jahren rauche ich ein halbes Schachtel Zigaretten-Telefink.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, jeden Tag ein Glas Wein trinke.
Herr Luss, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, ich habe nicht mit Drogen probiert.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall oder Zuckerkrankheit, Bruthochdruck?
Mein Vater ist mit 70 Jahren an Herzinfarkten gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist mit 65 Jahren alt an Mama-Karsinoma gestorben.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören.
Es war sehr lang, Doktor.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe zwei Geschwister.
Bruder oder Schwester?
Bruder und Schwester, ja. Aber sie sind gesunden, Doktor.
Sie sind gesunden.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren verfitbert und lebe allein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe sieben Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, alle sind gesund.
Das freut mich.
Sehr gut.
Sie sind jetzt 65 Jahre alt.
Arbeiten Sie noch oder sind Sie Rentner?
Ich bin jetzt Rentner, aber früher hatte ich eine Reiseagentur.
Okay.
Also haben Sie Stress im Alltag, Herr Los?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe viel Stress.
Ich habe sieben Kinder.
Alle sind gesund, aber es gibt viele Probleme.
Ich lebe allein.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Los, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, Doktor. Ich gehe schwimmen und Tennis spielen.
Okay.
Herr Los, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor. Was habe ich? Ich hatte viele Stärkereinheiten.
Ich fühle mich besser, aber ich habe Angst nach zwei oder drei Stunden oder Montag.
Herr Los, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen.
Ich vermute, dass Sie ein Problem mit der Nieren oder Handleiter haben.
Das kann ein Stein sein oder eine Infektion, Entzündung sein.
Aber es ist zu früh, etwas genau zu sagen.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Was ist Blut abnehmen, Doktor?
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen, Herr Los. Wir werden ein paar Werte kontrollieren, ob Sie eine Entzündung haben oder nicht.
Es könnte sein, dass ich Nierenkrebs habe. Ich habe gesagt, meine Mutter ist mit Krebs gestorben, Doktor.
Aufgrund der aktuellen Anamnese ist der Krebs eher unwahrscheinlich, Herr Los.
Herr Los, ich empfehle Ihnen positiv zu bleiben, da der Krebs in jedem Fall nicht die einzige Ursache ist.
Der Krebs ist nicht 100% vererblich. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Okay, Doktor. Bleibe ich im Krankenhaus oder?
Ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Danke, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke.
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über ihn berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön. Herr Horst Los ist 65 Jahre alt, 1,60 Meter groß und 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Los stellte sich heute bei uns seit 1,5 Stunden bestehender rechtseitiger flanken Schmerzen vor.
Dem Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien krampfartig und wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzen würden in den rechten, leichten Bereich ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10 mit 10 von 10 bewertet.
Die Einnahme von 600 Milligramm hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
600 Milligramm?
Ja.
Was?
Ibuprofen, Entschuldigung. Die Einnahme von 600 Milligramm Ibuprofen hat keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Der Patient berichtete über Dysurie, Hematurie und Polakisurie.
Außerdem klagte er über Fieber, aber der Patient habe sein Fieber nicht gemessen.
Er erwähnte keine bestimmten Auslöser für diese Schmerzen.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt.
Nausea mit zweimaliger grünlicher Emesis, schmerzbedingte Inappetens,
Gewichtszunahme von 2 bis 3 Kilogramm innerhalb von einer Woche,
schmerzbedingte Insomnie und chronische Diarrhea seit 10 Jahren.
Der Patient nehme dagegen Parenterol ein.
Er sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft und Reiseanamnese wurde verneint.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte er seit 15 Jahren bestehende Arthelhypertonie,
seit 14 Jahren bestehende Tendovaginitis am rechten Handgelenk
und vor zwei Jahren diagnostizierte Ganglion am rechten Handgelenk, die konservativ behandelt worden sei.
Er nehme Ramiplil 10 mg morgens ein und er benutze Dictophenaxsalbe gegen Tendovaginitis bei Bedarf.
Er sei bisher noch nie operiert worden und er habe Allergie gegen Gräserpollen,
die sich durch Pruritus und Renitis äußert.
Er habe Laktoseintoleranz, die sich durch Meteorismus, Abdominalschmerzen und Diarrhea äußert.
Er sei Raucher und er rauchte 10 Zigaretten täglich seit 30 Jahren, das entspricht 15 Pakiers.
Er trinke ein Glas Wein täglich und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass der Vater mit 70 Jahren an Myokardinfarkt verstorben sei
und die Mutter sei mit 65 Jahren an Mammakarzinom verstorben.
Er habe zwei Geschwister, die gesund seien und er sei verwitwet seit 5 Jahren.
Er habe 7 Kinder, die gesund seien und er wohne alleine.
Er sei Rentner, früher habe er in einer Reiseagentur gearbeitet.
Er habe Stress im Alltag und er schwimmt und spielt Tennis als Sport.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Pieronephritis, da der Patient typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Der Patient leidet unter flanken Schmerzen, krampfartige und wellenförmige Schmerzen.
Die Symptome für Pieronephritis sind Dysurie, Hematurie, Polakisurie und Fieber.
Als Differentialdiagnosen kommen Nephrolithiasis, Urolithiasis und Scholelithiasis in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei den Patienten die Vitaparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine Hautfarbeveränderung, Druckschmerzen, Abwehrspannung, Klopfschmerzen vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laborntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose sich zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, also Lekositin Saal, CAP, BSG, Nierenwerte, Leberwerte, Orientstatus, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien, wie zum Beispiel Steine, genau zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Abdominal Sonographie veranlassen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Bei der Ultraschalluntersuchung können wir Nierensteine, Schleudek, Gallenblasensteine oder Uretersteine feststellen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT des Abdomens durchführen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen und einen Venosynzugang legen.
Danach würde ich Analgetika, Spasmodetika, Antiemetika, Flüssigkeitszufuhr verabreichen.
Und ich würde danach ein urologisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn der Stein über 6 mm groß wäre, würde ich eine Operation oder andere Eingriffe, wie zum Beispiel Elektroepieken,
EVLS,
oder Transpercutane Neurolytotomie empfehlen.
Wenn die Entzündungssparameter hoch sind, würde ich auch den Patienten sicherlich eine Antibiotika verabreichen.
Wenn Sie dieser Vorgehensweise verstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall ein Urinantibiogramm durchführen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wenn der Patient an Pyronephritis leidet, sollen wir ein Urinantibiogramm durchführen, um die Erreger genau zu beurteilen und die effektive Antibiotik zu beurteilen.
Herr Kollegen, was sagen Sie? Was verursacht Pyronephritis?
Als Erreger sehen wir 80% der Fälle Echerechia coli, aber wir können auch Proteus oder Klebsiella sehen.
In diesem Fall führen Sie eine Urethroskopie durch?
Wenn wir einen Stein in der Harnwege oder in der Nieren feststellen, sollen wir eine Urethrographie durchführen, um die Diagnose genau zu beurteilen und gleichzeitig den Stein zu entfernen.
Denken Sie in diesem Fall eine Asteferanzei Diagnose Pyronephritis und eine Neven Diagnose Urolytiasis?
Der Patient leidet unter flanken Schmerzen auch Fieber. Der Patient hat sein Fieber nicht gemessen, aber wenn der Patient ein Fieber hat, ist mein Verdacht Diagnose Pyronephritis.
Aber wenn die Asteferanzei Diagnose Pyronephritis und Urolytiasis kommen, ist mein Verdacht Diagnose Pyronephritis.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, wenn der Patient Neurolytiasis hat, würde ich eine ESWL durchführen. Können Sie uns eine ESWL aufklären?
Ja gerne. Ich werde Sie über ESWL aufklären.
ESWL, Exokorporelle Stoßwellenlithotripsie ist eine Therapiemöglichkeit, mit der wir die Nierensteine oder Urethra-Steine behandeln.
Bei dieser Methode machen wir zuerst eine Unterscheidung und wir lokalisieren den Stein.
Dann geben wir eine starke Stoßwelle aus einem Gerät direkt den Stein von außen.
Diese Stoßwelle zerstört den Stein durch kleine Fragmente.
Diese Steinfragmente sollen mit dem Urin selbst ausscheiden.
Dafür soll der Patient nach der Untersuchung viel trinken, um die Steinfragmente einfach auszuscheiden.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 30-60 Minuten. Der Patient kann ein leichtes Druckgefühl spüren.
Dafür können wir dem Patienten ein Schmerzmittel bevor der Untersuchung geben.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient einige Komplikationen sehen, wie z.B. Nachblutungen oder Infektionen.
Aber das ist normalerweise ein risikoarme Untersuchung ohne Operationen oder Eingriff.
Können wir es mit der Eingriff mit Kollalithiasis machen?
Normalerweise benutzen wir diese Methode bei der Urolithiasis oder Nephrolithiasis.
Aber wir können diese Methode auch für Kollalithiasis.
In welcher Situation würden Sie eine Antibiotikum-Perepration?
Wir werden die Laborwerte kontrollieren, wenn die Entzündungparameter hoch sind, wie z.B. CAP, BSG oder Leukocytose.
Wenn wir Leukocyt oder Bakterien im Urin feststellen, dann können wir den Patienten eine Antibiotika anordnen.
Und andere Patienten?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Gibt es andere Patienten mit Antibiotikum behandelt?
Wenn wir bei den Patienten eine Pyrenephrithes denken, beginnen wir eine Antibiotika auf jeden Fall.
Ist es möglich, in diesem Fall eine Pyrenephrithes zu behandeln?
Der Patient wohnt in Deutschland, hat keine Reiseanamnese ins Ausland in der letzter Zeit.
Aber das ist eine Möglichkeit.
Wir sollen vielleicht die Reiseanamnese wieder fragen für Frühjahre.
Besonders in asiatischen Ländern.
Gibt es Umgebung, die Ähnlichkeit werden oder von besonderen Orten kommen?
Was meine ich damit? Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Gibt es jemand, der aus der betroffenen Region oder Land gekommen ist?
Er ist ein Reiseagentur. Das ist ein Risikofaktor bei diesem Patienten.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt. Gehen Sie bitte auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg in Ihrem Arbeitsweg.
Vielen Dank Herr Oberst, Sie sind sehr nett. Danke schön.